this story starts off in mesopotamia the
cradle of civilization
after several prehistoric periods had
passed the early bronze age brought with
it
the region's first true civilization a
complex society
characterized by advancements such as
domestication centralization
farming architecture and of course
writing that civilization
was sumo which consisted of groups of
people who settled along the valleys of
the tigris and euphrates rivers soon
enough cities started appearing such as
eredu uruk
uh uma and kish just to name some of the
bigger ones
the early dynastic period of summer
which started around 2900 bc
marked the appearance of kings who
reigned over these cities or
to give them their sumerian titles
lugels
this is how it went for several
centuries the sumerians were divided
into city-states each one with its own
ruler
sometimes getting along sometimes
fighting with each other but it was
inevitable that one day
one man would come along with grand
ambitions of conquest
and would succeed in bringing all the
sumerian cities under his control and
that man
was sargon who appeared at the end of
the 24th century bc
and founded the akkadian empire the
first empire in history
it probably will not surprise you to
discover that the life of sargon
is one big mystery to us there is only
one historical source that we can
consider to be somewhat contemporary to
him
and it's an ancient cuneiform text
called the sumerian king list which has
actually been found repeated
on multiple artifacts in various states
of preservation the most complete
version is on the world blundell prism
tablet that sits in the ashmolean museum
in oxford
dated to around 1800 bc it was still
made almost
500 years after sargon's time but that's
about as good as
we are going to get as his name suggests
the sumerian king list is a list of
well sumerian kings but it can hardly be
considered completely factual the kings
of the first dynasties were seen as demi
gods and
credited with reigns that lasted
hundreds even thousands of years and
some dynasties like that of the city of
lagash were
left off altogether for example the
first king mentioned on the list is
alulim who reigned over the city of
eredu which might be the oldest city in
mesopotamia the text
said after the kingship descended from
heaven the kingship
was in eredo in eredu alulim became king
he ruled for 28 800 years so you can see
why scholars might be disinclined to
take it at face value
as far as sargon was concerned the text
said then uruk was defeated and the
kingship was taken to agarde
in a guard a sargon whose father was a
gardener the cupbearer of uzzababa
became king the king of agarde who built
a guardi he ruled for 56
years this would place sargon's reign
between 2335 and 2279 bc
although there are multiple chronologies
used by scholars and there is no exact
consensus on those dates
because of his power and success sargon
became an important figure to the
babylonians and assyrians who
came after him and they wrote multiple
accounts about his exploits
although these were written well over a
thousand years after sargon's death
and they were almost certainly legendary
they are what we have to go
on and scholars reluctantly accept them
on the basis
that they were likely derived from much
older acadian sources that are now lost
which probably
had some kernels of truth in them going
by these legends sargon's rise to power
should be credited to the goddess inanna
who was the sumerian goddess of laven
beauty but also
of war oddly enough in text sargon
always praised inanna and
claimed that he was under her divine
protection in turn he helped transform
her from a minor deity into one of the
most important gods of ancient
mesopotamia she would be later worshiped
by the babylonians and the assyrians
under the name
ishtar sargon even had one of his high
priestesses named enerjana compose
hymns about inanna and here are two
notable facts about
anedwana number one she is identified as
the daughter of sargon although
we're not sure if this was simply a
title or meant an actual blood relative
and two
living almost 4 300 years ago she is
usually considered the earliest author
in history who is identified by
name back to sargon though well his
birth and childhood are described in a
neo-assyrian text that
has partly survived it said sargon the
mighty king king of agarde
am i my mother was a changeling my
father
i knew not my brothers of my father
loved the hills my city
is azapuranu which is situated on the
banks of the euphrates
my changeling mother conceived me in
secret she bore me
she set me in a basket of rashes with
bitumen she sealed my lid she cast me
into the river which rose not over me
the river bore me up and carried me to
ackee the drawer of water
akki the drawer of water lifted me out
as he dipped his
ewe akki the drawer of water took me and
his son and reared me akki the drawer of
water
appointed me as his gardener when i was
a gardener ishtar granted me her love
this is one translation there are others
and while they vary slightly they get
the same message across
in this case his changeling mother
refers to her being a high priestess
while there are
undoubtedly mythical elements to this
origin story there are also parts which
are
accepted as plausible facts about
sargon's life for starters
that his birthplace was azapuranu a town
situated somewhere on the banks of the
euphrates whose exact location remains a
mystery further that he was the son of a
gardener and
he may or may not have been adopted
after being abandoned by his birth
mother
of course it is also possible that none
of this is true and
some scholars have argued that sargon
intentionally gave himself a modest
upbringing to turn him into
a man of the people character
contrasting the sumerian kings who all
glorified their bloodlines and royal
lineages
[Music]
assuming that these anti-deliverable
texts have some sort of truth to them
we move on to another crucial part of
sargon's life the
time when he took power the story comes
from a different source and takes place
an uncertain number of years after
sargon was found and raised by a
gardener named aki
although this text identifies sargon's
father as lai bum
under unknown circumstances sargon had
become the cupbearer of king
uz baba ruler of the sumerian city of
kish
uzibaba is also mentioned in the
sumerian king list so at the very least
we have
some confirmation that he actually
existed for some reason
he could not put into words the king was
scared of sargon according to the text
he became
frightened in his residence like a lion
he urinated
sprinkling his legs and the urine
contained blood and pus
he was troubled he was disturbed like a
fish living in brackish water
one day he saw sargon sleeping and
groaning in his sleep indicating that he
was having a vivid dream or perhaps a
vision orzababa had the cupbearer
brought to him and told him to describe
his dream
truthfully sargon said that inanna had
appeared to him as a young woman as high
as the heavens and as broad as the earth
and then she drowned the king
in a river of blood this was perhaps not
the smartest thing to admit to king
uzzababa
who now wanted targon dead but he did
not want to do the deed himself maybe
out of fear
that he might be punished by the gods
instead he sent sargon to a temple named
isa kill to deliver a bronze mirror to
the chief smith
there the smith had orders to throw both
sargon and the mirror into the moulds of
his statues sargon did as he was told
but goddess inanna intervened and
stopped him from entering the temple
instead he only went as far as the gate
and left the mirror there and then
returned to the palace a few days later
the king sent sargon to the city of uma
with
a message for king lugel's age c
unbeknownst to sargon the
message simply said to kill the person
who delivered it anyone know what
happens next
well your guess is as good as ours
frustratingly the rest of the legend
just didn't survive so
we don't know there's just a few bits
and pieces but not enough to tell the
whole story we're not sure
how sargon survived this encounter and
then managed to use sir power from king
uzaba
but well he totally did we should have a
quick mention here
of lugel zaghazi although he started as
king of uma he conquered multiple
sumerian cities such as uruk lagash ur
and even kish
at one point his kingdom stretched out
over most of sumer and
he did this before sargon so some
scholars argue that he should be the one
with the claim
to the first empire it all boils down to
what we consider to be the differences
between a kingdom
and an empire especially in the context
of the ancient world over four thousand
years ago and cultural identities were
not so well defined a kingdom is
homogeneous its size is not that
important but it consists of a people
who share
a history a language and a culture all
the people that lugol zaghazi conquered
were sumerians so
it would probably be correct to say that
he ruled over a large kingdom
rather than an empire meanwhile sargon
also went next door and conquered his
neighbors
most notably the elamites his dominion
was undoubtedly a multi-ethnic affair
and would count as an
empire by any modern definition
regardless of the actual title he used
[Music]
according to the legend of sargon he was
the one who founded the city of akkad
also spelled agade which would go on to
serve as the capital of his empire it
was also the birthplace of the akkadian
language which is one of the oldest
semitic languages in the world
it was similar to other east semitic
languages but unsurprisingly
it was also heavily influenced by
sumerians since the acadians adopted the
cuneiform writing of their neighbors
acadian became the most common language
in mesopotamia for around 1
800 years being adopted by the later
babylonian and assyrian empires until
eventually getting passed out in favor
of old aramaic as far as the city itself
is concerned scholars are convinced that
it genuinely existed
it has been referenced in hundreds of
other sources most of them in cuneiform
however the location of a cad
remains a mystery at the moment it is
considered a lost city but
archaeologists do have some
ideas on where it could have been so it
would not be too surprising if the ruins
of a cad would
be uncovered sometime in the future at
that point the discovery of new acadian
artifacts would probably shed some more
light on sargon himself but
for now we make do with what we have and
one important source is the tablets from
nippur which
are old babylonian artifacts recovered
over a hundred years ago from the ruins
of the sumerian city of nepur located in
modern-day iraq
like all babylonian artifacts they were
made centuries after the death of sargon
and the fall of his empire but they
contained copies of inscriptions which
were
once part of acadian statues located in
the temple dedicated to the god enlil
not only do these inscriptions
talk about sargon's rise to power but
also about the later conquests of his
successes
omitting all the royal titles and the
self-congratulatory talk that is always
present in these kinds of monuments here
is what the tablets have to say
about sargon sargon king of akkad he
conquered the city of uruk and tore down
its walls he challenged uric in battle
and took lukalzagi the king of uruk
prisoner
in the course of battle he led him in a
wooden collar to the gate of enlil
sargon king of akad challenged her in
battle and defeated the city and
destroyed its walls he defeated ian in
kamara and destroyed its walls and
destroyed its land from lagash to the
sea he washed his weapons
in the sea he challenged umar in a
battle and he defeated the city and
destroyed its walls de sargon
king of the land and lil gave no rival
and lil gave him the upper sea in the
lower sea
from the lower sea citizens of akkad
held the government mari and elam were
subject to sargon king of the land he
restored kish
and let them occupy the city the message
actually ends with a curse saying that
whoever will damage this inscription
may shemash tear out his roots and
destroy his seed
as you can see not a lot of detail there
but it does provide some
useful information regarding the size of
sargon's empire and
some of the main cities that became a
part of his domain
what's interesting is kish the city that
sargon once called home when he was the
king's cupbearer it doesn't say
that the acadian ruler conquered it in
battle but rather that he restored it
and that he allowed its former
inhabitants to live in the city
although by no means a certainty it is
feasible that sargon somehow usurped the
throne of kish then
used its resources to found the city of
akkad and amass a military powerful
enough to conquer suma
one city at a time
speaking of conquest sargon was not
finished once he had the whole of
sumeria under his control
since nobody in the region could match
his power he began expanding into new
lands
perhaps his most noteworthy foreign foe
was elam to the east a civilization
that would remain a powerful threat in
the area for thousands of years
at that point it was ruled by the owan
dynasty but around 2300 bc sargon
conquered its capital susa
and deposed king lu ishan from
inscriptions we know that in the east
sargon also fought and bested parashum
better known under its sumerian name
marhashi the existence of this
settlement was first attested in
acadian sources and just like a cad
today mahashi
is a lost city whose location remains
unknown however it appears
that the distance between it and the
heart of the empire made it difficult
for the akkadian king to maintain
control over it and it was the source of
frequent revolts which had to be put
down by sargon and the rulers who came
after him
even so it could have been worse as not
all cities targeted by the king
ended up a part of the acadian empire
some of them were simply destroyed like
kazalu today kazulu is
nothing more than the name of a city
that supposedly existed once somewhere
in mesopotamia we don't know what they
did to earn the fierce ire of sargon but
according to a babylonian tablet he
pretty much wiped the city off the face
of the earth he marched into kasalu and
turned kazulu into a ruined heap so that
there was not even a perch for a bird
left
further up north sargon captured cities
located in modern day syria such as mari
tuttle and ebla according to one
babylonian narrative titled king of
battle
sargon went so far north that he entered
anatolia a peninsula which is today part
of turkey
there he conquered the city state called
purashanda which was rained over by a
king named nour de gal who
humbly accepted acadian rule and
recognized the superior might of sargon
the same account also claims that sargon
then
sailed the mediterranean sea and
captured kaptara which is probably
cypress
some scholars consider this last
chronicle to be entirely fictional while
the full reach of the acadian empire is
uncertain many believe that it did not
extend northwest of the euphrates
however
if it is indeed genuine then sargon's
empire stretched out significantly
further than one would even think
possible at the time
as the conquests kept coming sargon
began learning a lesson that many other
rulers would have to learn after him the
more you expanded your empire the harder
it became to keep it that way it is said
that he installed governors in every new
conquered city the
citizens of a cad as they were called as
their name implies they were all from a
cad but they also
all spoke acadian helping to spread the
language throughout the region and
turning it into the lingua franca of
mesopotamia for almost 2000 years that
being said this was still not enough
even the sources that praised sargon
still make mention of numerous revolts
and riots that
he had to contend with throughout his
reign and well into his old age
this is described by the chronicle of
early kings afterwards
all of the lands rebelled again and
surrounded him in a guarde
sargon went out to fight and brought
about their defeat he overthrew them and
overpowered their extensive army
afterwards
batu attacked sargon in full force and
called him to arms
sargon set an ambush and completely
defeated them he overpowered their
extensive army and
sent their possessions into a cad the
same chronicle also said that saron's
actions angered the god marduk who then
cursed him with insomnia and brought
about a famine that destroyed his people
which in turn led to more rebellions
despite the numerous uprisings sargon
always came out on top
at least according to all the chronicles
however they were written
in his honor after all so it would have
been unlikely that they would include
his failures but at the very least we
can say that nobody rose up to pose a
serious threat to his empire
not yet anyway furthermore going by all
the available evidence argon had a very
long reign the sumerian king list says
56 years and while there are modern
chronologies that argue for a lower
number they still say that his reign
lasted for over 40 years
it is generally believed that sargon
died of natural causes given his old age
but we can't attest to that with any
certainty
after his death the acadian empire
lasted for around another 140 years
he was succeeded by his son rimoshu had
to contend with numerous revolts that
unsurprisingly
appeared after the demise of sargon his
reign lasted less than a decade and
presumably
he had no viable heirs upon his death
because ramosh was succeeded by his
brother another son of sargon named
manishtutsu he was followed by his own
son narem sin
who gave himself the title of king of
the four quarters of the earth and
brought the acadian empire to the peak
of its power but after the peak of
course
there is nowhere to go but down and the
death of naram sin marked the beginning
of the downfall of the acadian empire
eventually the dynasty was toppled by
the gooti or gutiens a
group of tribes that descended from the
zagrous mountains upon the fertile
fields provided by the tigers and
euphrates they started with frequent
raids and other hit-and-run tactics that
not only crippled the acadian empire
but did not provide us enough time to
respond eventually the guardians charged
a cad and laid waste to it so that
even today we don't know where it's
located there is a reason why some
scholars divide the history of ancient
mesopotamia
into the pre-sargonic and post-sargonic
eras
before him the region mainly consisted
of city-states sure
they still ward with each other and some
kingdoms expanded their borders well
beyond their original cities
but the idea of conquering and
controlling the entire region was
considered
unachievable after sargon though this
became the goal
for many ambitious civilizations first
came the apple mentioned guardians then
there was the sumerian dynasty this time
centered around the city of uh although
it was also short-lived afterwards there
was a millennium where the assyrians and
the babylonians swapped regional
supremacy between each other several
times before both were subdued and
conquered by the new archanimid empire
under cyrus the great his persian empire
lasted for a few hundred years before it
also fell this time to the macedonian
might of alexander the great the size of
empires grew even larger
as did the ambitions and lust for power
of their rulers who wanted to conquer
the world
but it all started with sargon of a cad
so i really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below don't forget
to subscribe and as always
thank you for watching